we have a
system in our country
and a culture
that is very unforgiving so it is fine
that there are consequences for bad
actions some of those can rightfully
include incarceration but what's not
fine is when someone has done their time
paid their dues that they are forever
branded yes as less than a full citizen
as less than a full human being and
denied the opportunity to become
contributing members of society
[Music]
can you believe it that's right i'm
still here living inside this tent on
top of this rooftop
bringing to you the attention and
awareness that you need to know about
the violence on the south side of
chicago but also to build a community
center on this much needed block called
o block it's called o block because it's
named after a young man named od perry
who was shot and killed the game took oh
in his name and start calling it o block
well we decided we like the o but we're
going to change it to opportunity block
i want to thank fox for giving me the
opportunity every single day to bring to
you rooftop revelations where i share
with you my viewpoints thoughts and
opinions on matters as it relates to
violence in chicago but critical issues
across our great country and every now
and then i get to bring you a very
special guest
and today i'm really excited for our
guests
go ahead and introduce yourself jeff i'm
jeff korzanik i'm an economic researcher
and author and the chief investment
strategist of fifth third bank
and the author of this wonderful book
called
untapped talent that we're going to talk
about
today
and when we talk about untapped talent
one of your submissions how second
chance hiring works for your business
and the community
uh
i want to ask you when it comes to
second chance hiring and
returning citizens people who
are returning into society from prison
why do we have this problem
with these individuals in the first
place what's the problem
the problem is
a universal human condition that
young people make mistakes and in
particular young men make mistakes
and unfortunately we have a
system in our country
and a culture
that is very unforgiving so it is fine
that there are consequences for bad
actions some of those can rightfully
include incarceration but what's not
fine is when someone has done their time
paid their dues that they are forever
branded yes as less than a full citizen
as less than a full human being and
denied the opportunity to become
contributing members of society yeah so
why is it then why do you feel that
we've made it so much more difficult for
these individuals
uh to get jobs and to re-enter back into
society well part of the problem is just
our approach to
uh uh to justice system has overly
incarcerated because overly relied on
incarceration
and then we live in a society that has
changed over time so part of this is the
typical uh you know business owners
may have had no interaction with people
with criminal records and so they're
they're the others so they it's harder
for them to understand the situation
that could have brought them to this
place and then there's a lot of fear of
legal liability if you hire it's
technically called negligent hiring
liability um if you hire someone with a
criminal record is that putting you at
additional legal risk um and there are
answers to all of these
but we've also had until recently
um just a surplus of labor in this
country so we never had to worry about
it there was never a need to dig deeper
into our population from a business
perspective moral perspective absolutely
and that's changing um but but it's left
us in a position and if i may give you
the numbers absolutely please 19 million
americans have a felony conviction
and that includes one in three black men
in america wow and
this has become an incredible barrier to
being able to participate in society
taking care of your family and it causes
intergenerational poverty absolutely and
and that's the reason why it's so
important that i talk with you because
that and that people hear and understand
what's going on when you say one in
three
african-american meals and then um
the fact that it's creating generational
poverty
two things that we're trying to
alleviate that we're trying to fix
can you tell us how do we fix that
because here at project hood we want to
fix that problem how do we go about
fixing that issue
so so it has to start with the business
community
they have to become open to this
and not just
open in sort of a um
a easy to say way oh we're a fair
employer they have to have to dig into
their process and say how are we
unintentionally excluding people what do
we have to do
and a key component of what they have to
do is to partner with organizations like
project hood because you as an employer
need someone who is going to help
prepare
young people who've made mistakes and
people of all ages who made mistakes
help prepare them and critically for the
employer
help determine who's truly ready to be a
good employee and then employers also
have to learn
that this group may come with gaps any
any talent full comes with gaps things
that you need absolutely
the gaps of this group are things we're
not used to thinking about in the
business community access to
transportation housing
and that's the other role that
organizations like project could have to
help provide those
wraparound services in partnership with
the business community you know i have a
question i really want to ask you
because i'm really interested you know
when we talk about these returning
citizens a lot of times there's not a
lot of individuals who really care about
this type of effort
what is it that caused you
to come up with this idea i mean what
happened that said that jeff said listen
i'm gonna help with this area i'm gonna
help fix it what what what happened so i
have two answers here's my official
answer and then i'll give you the
unofficial okay the official answer is
i'm a banker
and
our
companies we bank need employees
and i discovered that there are
employers out there
that have
created pathways for people who've been
marginalized from the labor force so
this is the solution that supports our
employers and also makes our communities
better so what better role for a banker
yeah absolutely here's the unofficial
answer my father who uh who passed away
in 2003 was my hero i'm 60 years old and
my dad is still my hero
he was first in family to go to college
he was raised in deep poverty and he
never forgot his roots and as a kid
um he
would return on weekends to do what he
called errands and i later realized was
just visiting his old neighborhood
and um one day when i was eight or ten i
went along with him and he introduced me
to a friend of his they had a nice
conversation
and when we walked away my dad said you
know my friend was in prison
and i you know curious said i said for
what and my dad said for murder a crime
of passion and then my dad said
something that stuck with me forever he
said he's done his time
and i think that is
something that drives me as an american
i'm the son and grandson of immigrants
this country has been the land of second
chances for us i want everyone to have a
second chance an opportunity to take
part in the american dream absolutely so
jeff when when these
brothers and sisters who are returning
citizens into our community from the
prison system
what is their response how do they
respond to the things that you're doing
for them and helping them find place
in society what's their response uh you
know i didn't understand it at first
people would hug me
i get letters from prison um i i got one
letter that really touched me and and
changed something i did with the book i
got a letter from a federal prison in
colorado and i've written an article in
behrens financial magazine about the
importance of giving opportunities and
this pathway to hiring
and
this gentleman wrote me
from prison and said
your article hangs on our prison library
wall and gives all of us here hope
so it was important to me that this
message which is really intended for the
business community non-profits and
government and general
public who wants to learn more about the
justice system how we can get this make
this right
um but i also wanted this book to go
into correctional facilities so a uh
a industry peer a colleague i met at a
conference who wanted to help funded
sending so far 500 of the books to
prison libraries
and the very first part of this book
it's i i i'm pretty sure i can guarantee
that this is the only business book that
starts out with a note to the currently
incarcerated which essentially says you
think you're a burden you're not you're
a resource and i thought people who are
in the system need to know that there
are those of us in the business
community that understand that they are
a resource absolutely and i know we're
going to be using a lot of the
principles from the book with our um uh
reentry program and so we're really
grateful and thankful
but as before we go
just tell us
where do you see the future of this
going what's the future of of this type
of market that you're talking about this
untapped talent i i'm actually very
optimistic because in my entire lifetime
my entire you know nearly uh 30 35 40
year business career
we've always had a surplus of labor the
business community didn't really have to
care about these issues yeah
we stopped having enough babies 20 and
30 years ago in this country we have a
labor shortage that simply isn't going
away right and for the first time
everyone in the business community has
to care about these issues and has to
look to creating pathways for people
who've been marginalized the business
community
are really good problem solvers and
they've never had to help work on these
on these problems and i think and and i
have to commend project hood you've done
an incredible job in partnering with the
business community in chicago already
and really unusual for organizations
like this um this is
an opportunity to put all those talents
to work to making this right and getting
the business community to understand
that people who are just as involved
are their future workforce how do you
want them treated and that's that's
going to result in very positive change
absolutely there's one more thing i know
i was going to i just said it was going
to be last question but there's one more
thing asking an author you're talking
more about it i think the title of the
book yes untapped talent
can you you know
that that's an interesting title what
what made you say untapped talent why is
that
so my argument to the business community
you know i go through the argument of
why this labor shortage is here why it's
not going away that's just simple
demographics and how critical it is
but i also urge them to look at this as
a true talent
wow what i'm really concerned about
today is businesses are going to go back
to something we've seen before gee i
can't find labor i guess i'm going to
lower my standards that's not it exactly
this is looking at people who've had
unique life experiences that are
non-traditional but bring real talent to
the situation
and so i want businesses to understand
that the core way you approach a talent
find who's a good fit for what you're
trying to do with your enterprise and
then critically understand the gaps they
have and what you need to do to support
them
you don't even have to do it alone you
can partner with
people like project hood government
agencies all sorts of folks are there to
help
partner with them to to allow those
employees to thrive that's how you treat
a talent pool that would work with
graduates from
university of chicago business school
yeah but they're picked over yeah the
reason this works so well for businesses
the way they get such highly
engaged loyal employees is because this
is a town pool that hasn't been picked
over it's an unkept opportunity for the
business community absolutely well i
want to say thank you you know i love
talking about second chances
everybody who knows me know that i'm a
person that believes in giving people a
lot of grace
you know i preach the bible one of the
reasons why i preach the bible is
because it's a book of of giving people
second chances where you're talking
about moses who was a murderer david who
was an adulterer
jonah who just didn't want to obey god i
mean the bible is replete it's for paul
who was a killer of christians i mean
it's full of people who were making
mistakes but god used them and so i want
to thank you for writing such a great
book i want to thank you for sharing
your principles with the american with
the world and hopefully we can find a
place
for more of these returning citizens
back into our society and hopefully
hopefully give them a second chance
thank you thank you for being here
tonight too i hope you don't freeze
tonight we're gonna make sure you try to
stay a little warm but thanks listen
it's been a blessing thank you for
tuning in to rooftop revelations as
always i want to thank eli steele our
producer for producing such a great show
i want to thank terrell for
suffering in this cold weather with us
to film it but most of all i want to
thank fox for giving me this platform i
know you don't have to but you do it
every single day and i get letters from
people all across america
talking about how inspired and
encouraged they are so
i salute you fox for having the courage
uh to allow this platform to be uh
displayed thank you so very much and as
i always say another rooftop revelation
god bless you god bless america and
until tomorrow another rooftop
revelation peace
you